LeBron James he brutalized it get that
weak stuff out of here that blocks
against the land on the other nights yes
Prince and shrewder coming behind doing
a good job of helping out his teammate
Ron called for it against Martin 6-10
side too easy for the king the nice pick
and roll sniff drops until the brown and
he throws a man down son is coaching
against the dad's employer yep good pick
and roll situation of jr. with an ice
pick nice pass to the brown the bronze
on the hammer down catching the defender
and he's just playing basketball but
that being said there's not a team Lee
you would love to have Marcus long a
little still came to the hoop
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
doesn't matter
LeBron James rankings in a playground by
himself
6650 - what time it is fall back baby is
good night to fall away jumper there
you've got to have strong legs to do
that from that distance 79 64
inside of juniors got that beautiful
dime from Iran Jane is probably the best
passer from the pocket from that
position there on the foul in the mood
you get better as they're saying fellas
which is what they did in the second
quarter when the vets turn the game
around on the cut Channing Frye came to
the ball goes in the left hand reach
good pass to luck movie without that
ball is there such a beautiful thing
good defense by 11 the no close James
with muscle anybody nice crossover move
but there's to be LeBron on the a so
against Green is he good right hand on
the baseline
no left-hander oh he just went to the
[ __ ] 9o said I dare you to stop